l'invité du journal rené lévesque
premier ministre du québec monsieur
bonsoir la crise a souvent de visage
pour la majorité des français le pénible
et l'insupportable la supportable c'est
le chômage nous allons en parler dans
une minute le pénible c'est par exemple
le prix de l'essence augmenté depuis
samedi nous le savons tous ce n'est pas
fini il y a deux heures nous avons
appris que l'arabie saoudite avait
décidé d'augmenter le prix de son
pétrole cheikh kabbani n'en a pas dit
plus il se trouvait comme tous ses
collègues des pays exportateurs de
pétrole à bali au sommet de l'opep
un sommet qui veut à tout prix garder
d'unités de ses membres c'est ainsi que
l'on a pu voir côte à côte c'est paraît
simplement en dépit de l'ordre
alphabétique par le représentant de
l'indonésie
on a donc pu voir les iraniens et les
irakiens qui se battent toujours les
iraniens avaient quand même tenu à
garder une chaise vide loyer pour y
exposer une photo de leur ministre
retenu prisonnier depuis un mois et demi
à bagdad mais en dépit de cet éclat il
semble que les exportateurs de brut
veille d'afficher un accord sur
l'essentiel
conséquence directe donc le chômage le
choc pétrolier dans n'est pas la seule
cause c'est vrai mais ils comptent pour
beaucoup et les chiffres que vient de
publier le ministère du travail ne sont
pas fameux on compte désormais dans le
pays un million six cent treize mille
demandeurs d'emploi soit 1,8 pour cent
de plus que le mois dernier en données
corrigées c'est bien sûr un peu moins
mais est toujours en augmentation
ces chiffres bien sûr recouvre des
situations très différentes
andré bergeron disait aujourd'hui que
l'on avait dépassé le million de
chômeurs indemnisés mais il ya les
autres et notamment ceux qui arrivent en
fin de droits qui ne peuvent plus
prétendre à aucune allocation
c'est évidemment la situation extraire
extrême et et c'est celle là qui a
retenu l'attention de jacques mannino
fougères ille-et-vilaine 20 me d'actifs
de 1500 demandeur d'emploi et parmi eux
deux sont chômeurs arrivés en fin de
droits rayés des listes npa au bout de
trois ans de pointage de 6 au moins de
50 ans de cinq ans ils ont plus de 50
ans ne touche plus aucune indemnité une
population qui se cachent conteuse de
son inactivité et que les syndicats eux
mêmes n'arrivent plus à touches
sur les 200 qu'on a à peu près
répertorier les gens nagent pas une
cinquantaine simplement qu'ils ont
contact avec les organisations
syndicales
nous on a envie de 12 qui sont venus là
terminant slovène soir et on a surtout
vu des célibataires qui était sans
aucune ressource
bon ben quelques-uns avaient encore
leurs parents temps en temps ils vont
manger chez les parents ils ont des
dettes de loyer enfin ils vont au bout
de pain de viande ce qui est lui nommé
mans et ça c'est je crois que c'est ce
qui plaît au pru l'autre jour il ya une
dame qui nous disait dans l'union locale
qu'elle qu'elle était réduite à manger
des brisures de riz elle avait des
bandes y en de 36 francs de viande pas
par quinzaine cesseront de pain voilà
bon le pour se chauffer bon bain elle
fait les chantiers un petit peu pour
récupérer du bois
autrement ce serait pas pour s'habiller
bombe elle récupère d'événements ici et
là que les gens veulent bien donner
vraiment c'est des gens qui sont laissés
pour contre quoi
je vais donc quand est-ce que vous avez
quitté cette usine pas dernière fois
pour le 13 février 1976 et de cuivre n'a
pas eu de travail
merci j'ai renvoyé le déçoit vous avez
l'air de nuit chez prévost gt3 mois
jardinier à la ville de fougères déjà
effectué plusieurs coups de mains depuis
que je suis licencié l'écho de masse les
petits renversement regardez quinze
jours dans un endroit j'ai été sept
joueurs et demi on était venu chercher
un midi j'ai là ils avaient réellement
besoin d'un golf pour pour dépanner et
j'ai demandé pour que je puisse passer
il ou non une moue pour garder ce n'est
pas maintenant
pour l'instant on voit j'arrive en fin
de droits donc pour l'instant
il n'y a rien de j'attends la suite des
événements pourquoi ça c'est difficile à
toucher à dent contre les chômeurs qui
arrivent comme ça enfin le droit au
repos ce cas ils ont ri sont tellement
léger qui ne veulent plus qu'ils veulent
même pas discuté avec personne parce que
c'est trop c'est trop publiant savait
depuis le temps qu'on est
ça fait cinq ans que ça dure bonvin
physiquement moralement humainement ça
devient impossible et semaines
maintenant
le premier ministre a dit que les
chômeurs devrait créer des entreprises
car oui alors je me demande avec quoi
là c'est vraiment de la pure démagogie
de sa part parce que j'estime que ce
n'est pas sérieux
alors les chaînes ont déjà pour trop de
vent pour yves et créer des entreprises
mais avec quoi à l'assemblée nationale
nous sommes dirigés que par des
technocrates et des intellectuels qui
s'était excusé les avocats les médecins
les pharmaciens
c'est une fois qu'ils sachent à qui se
passe dans les entreprises tout le monde
l'ongle avec l'emploi et le chômage
depuis cinq ans que ça dure en fin de
compte on n'est pas plus avancé
aujourd'hui combien sont ils à glisser
ainsi hors de la société
il n'y a pas de chiffre précis définitif
mais selon les études
leur nombre varie entre 50 et 100 mille
l'équivalent de la ville de calais ou de
la rochelle alors devant ce constat que
vous l'avenir
d'abord la réponse du cnpf qui s'affirme
moins pessimiste pour les mois à venir
dans sa lettre de conjoncture il parle
de stabilisation et non pas de récession
autres diagnostics celui de l' ocde qui
fêtait aujourd'hui son 20e anniversaire
valéry giscard d'estaing s'est rendu
pour l'occasion à son siège au château
de la muette à paris et a insisté sur la
nécessité pour les pays industrialisés
de coopérer afin de surmonter at il dit
la crise la plus sérieuse la plus
terrible est la plus éprouvante que le
monde ait connue depuis les années 30
conclusion le chef de l'état le retour à
l'isolationnisme serait une faute encore
renault a voulu faire arthaud en arrière
à mi chemin entre la création ocde en 60
et les années 80 il a cherché à savoir
comment il ya dix ans s'engage et la
décennie 70 quels étaient les espoirs
des pays riches
vous verrez qu entre les espoirs et la
réalité
la différence est cruel 1970 l' ocde
fête son dixième anniversaire
le nouveau président pompidou entame son
septennat sous le signe des téléphones
et des autoroutes rue de martignac les
meilleurs planificateurs du monde
selon le nouvel observateur engage la
bataille du sixième plan on rêve d'une
croissance à la japonaise
on fera 6 % par an le patronat voudrait
8%
c'est le tout pour l'industrie lusine
avant l'hôpital chaban delmas premier
ministre présente sa politique concorde
l'atome et la télé couleur
les capitaines d'industrie célèbrent
leur premier succès à l'exportation
quelques journalistes reviennent de
l'exposition d'osaka au japon c'est
l'illusion technique et great il en
contemplant le robot fusil pan qui nous
donne des cauchemars
aujourd'hui en fait l'optimisme cool
comme le pétrole en abondance
on vient de découvrir un gisement
considérable en mer du nord et avec le
baril à 1 $ 80 sous tes permis aux pays
riches ceux de l'oscd personne n'imagine
que dix ans plus tard le même bar il
faudra presque 35 dollars quand les
journaux parlent du pétrole c'est parce
qu'il trop lui le grand public découvre
l'écologie science de la richesse et
s'interroge le progrès conduire est il à
l'asphyxient ses angoisses fugitive
n'empêche pas la france de caresser la
civilisation des loisirs
la semaine de 35 heures est pour bientôt
avec plus de vacances plus de
disponibilité enfin nous allons bien
vivre
il sera peut être temps alors de se
préoccuper du tiers-monde et comme on
dit d'enrayer la détérioration des
termes de l'échangé
un terrible féminisme qui suscite plus
de discours que d'actions concrètes
aujourd'hui dix ans après en pleine
crise les pays industrialisés des fours
que leur survie passe par le
développement des pays pauvres
en 1970 ce qui préoccupe les français
c'est l'inflation
avec 6 3% de hausse sur une année les
prix viennent de battre un record vieux
de 20 ans cela dit la coccinelle ou
vettel imaginer qu'elle compterait 22
mille francs en 81
le président de république et son épouse
le premier ministre demain aux obsèques
de joël le theule décédé dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche des obsèques qui
auront lu à sable et la ville dont il
était le maire
à 16 heures le chef de l'état vient
d'écrire à la merde de joël le theule
votre fils lui dit il est peut-être un
ministre exemplaire nous le pleurons
tous il était courageux simple et
compétents un nouveau sondage pour les
présidentielles sondage figaro sofres au
deuxième tour valéry giscard d'estaing
56% françois mitterrand 44 %
c'est-à-dire trois points de mieux pour
le leader socialiste et donc trois
points de moins pour le chef de l'état
parti communiste le deuxième adjoint au
maire de carcassonne démissionne de ses
fonctions et du pcma la pelouse
protestent contre la politique de l'urss
en aveugle en afghanistan la gestion
municipale de sa ville et le mode de
désignation de georges marchais comme
candidat enfin le duo réquisitoire de
marie france garaud à l'encontre du
président marc public elle a rendu
public aujourd'hui la lettre qu'elle lui
avait adressées vous nous avez trompés
dit elle et dans les quelques raisons
qu'elle a maintenant se présenter contre
valéry giscard d'estaing
elle cite notamment la politique
étrangère j'ai pensé lorsqu'il a été élu
comme je l'indiquais dans la lettre à
laquelle vous faites allusion qu'il
mènerait une politique inspirée
des mêmes principes que celui qui avait
été son prédécesseur et une politique
qui soit fondé sur l'indépendance de la
france et sa prospérité économique
j'ai été amenée à constater comme
beaucoup de français que la politique
étrangère de la france dans la mesure où
on pouvait l'apprécier actuellement
paraissait une politique plutôt orienté
vers une sorte de neutralisent mme de
non alignement et que la politique
économique était un échec
dans ces conditions non seulement j'ai
modifié ma position en ce qui concerne
le président de la république mais
j'étais amené candidate contre lui
la démission d'un haut responsable de la
sécurité nucléaire en france jugeant
servant socata général du comité
interministériel qui la contrôle a cessé
ses fonctions il ya un mois et s'élève
de manière le point qu'il révèle
aujourd'hui visiblement jean servant
reproche à son ministre de tutelle andré
giraud de ne pas porter l'attention
nécessaire à ce problème de la sécurité
ce qui a d'ailleurs suscité une question
du député socialiste paul quilès qui
s'inquiètent de cette absence de
précaution georges leclercq vous prêts
dans ce dossier il y un peu plus d'un an
le grand public découvre la sphère des
fissures les techniciens les ont
examinés avec des appareils spéciaux à
rayons x comme ici et très vite ils ont
acquis la certitude que ces fissures ne
sont pas assez dangereuse pour arrêter
le programme nucléaire français
d'où le démarrage de centrales comme
tricastin ou ont été prises ces images
est aussi gravelines dampierre et
bientôt le blade seulement le doute
commence à a germé le dogme de la
sécurité absolue de l'industrie atomique
était battue en brèche
tout cela se passe dans un contexte de
crise de l'énergie de pétrole rare et
cher où il faut des énergies nationales
pour cesser d'importer des barils de
plus en plus coûteux et de moins en
moins accessible alors c'est décidé le
gouvernement se lance à fond dans le
nucléaire on francise à coups d'études
des centrales d'origine américaine
il faut d'énergie
des kilowattheures c'est nucléaire qui
va en faire pour cela il faut le pousser
et rapidement
mais pour certains dans monsieur servant
responsable de la sécurité nucléaire on
privilégie désormais la production
d'énergie plutôt que la sécurité faute
de moyens il démissionne
ses motivations sont révélés ce matin
par le magazine le point qui publie une
lettre que monsieur cervin adressée au
ministre l'industrie
le premier ministre responsable de la
sécurité nucléaire contre répondent
rapidement questions posées par ce
problème et ce cube déjà de mieux faire
fonctionner cet élément vital notre
sécurité énergétique
conclusion de la cfdt la sécurité
nucléaire n'est pas d'assurer en france
a dit michel rolland le chasseur
français a trouvé un acheteur de plus
huit à neuf cents personnes pourraient
être réembauchés prochainement bernard
tapie et les syndics de l'ancienne
société ayant trouvé preneur mais la cgt
et la cfdt critique ces projets qui
passe également par l'évacuation des
locaux bref mais violent incident ce
matin à l'université nanterre des
militants d'extrême droite du but d'
sont venus lancer une action de
commandos il ya eu des heurts avec
d'autres étudiants et des
interpellations de la police bilan vingt
blessés 21h appellation le président de
l'université a porté plainte
une manifestation s'est organisée dans
l'après-midi à partir de la faculté de
jussieu et s'est retrouvé bloqué par la
police au pont de la concorde alors que
représente ce but d' groupe union droit
qui fait en entend parler de lui et
parfois comme ce matin violemment et
bien françois cornet vient d'effectuer
une enquête à la faculté de droit de la
rue d'assas l'université paris ii appelé
plus communément la fac d'assas a la
réputation d'être une bonne faculté de
droit mais également d'être le bastion
des étudiants d'extrême droite voire néo
nazis sur quinze mille étudiants
inscrits seuls quelque 2 à 300 manifeste
des idées d'extrême droite
reste que ces militants actifs règne en
maître dans l'université
grâce au gud une organisation musclé qui
tient sous sa coupe
l'ensemble des locaux de la rue d'assas
son style la manière forte
mais nous faisons pareil élan dans ses
facultés nous évitons qu'il y est
les éléments qui vendent ou de la merde
dans les yeux se lèvent la tête souvent
entendu assas comme parfois sciences po
chez les étudiants l'extrême droite
c'est que l'action de nettoyage comme
ils disent est nécessaire pour rétablir
l'ordre dans l'université
jusqu'où va la violence ici elle n'est
jamais très aigu
elle s'arrête à quelques distributions
de coups de matraque à quelques coups de
casque mais il n'y a jamais eu de
blessés graves
sauf sur les affiches car il est des
mouvements qui se plaisent à revendiquer
dénombre deux blessés très important
voire la puissance 13
il ne faut pas s'inquiéter parce qu'en
général il ne s'agit que d'égratignures
ou de quelques blessés légers vous ne
faites donc pas renier contrairement à
ce qu'on dit la terreur à l'université a
cité royale est pas de notre fret et
il serait plutôt dans notre attributions
de rétablir le
comment pourrions-nous l'ordre
oui une certaine conception de l'homme
assas du meeting de gauche du raku de la
ligue des droits de l'homme est
strictement interdite bref une
université bien propre sans grève ni
manifestation à la grande satisfaction
de son président et de l'administration
je voudrais préciser tout de même que
depuis quatre ans nous n'avons pas eu un
jour de grève n'ont pas eu un court
perturbé qui n'ont pas eu un examen
remis pas une séance de travaux dirigés
qu'elle était retardé c'est notre image
de marque alors sur le plan de la
coloration politique des universités ont
dit nous sommes une université de droite
alors j'aimerais bien que l'on me dise
ce qu'est une université de droite et ce
qu'aimer verse idées de gauche ne pas
avoir de drogue est rhabillé
convenablement et avoir les cheveux
courts c'est être de droite et bien et
j'accepte volontiers pour une université
soit considérée comme une université de
droite
un président d'université en fait sans
problème mais il est vrai que le guide
concentre l'agitation sur d'autres lieux
descend à l'université de tolbiac mis à
trois semaines cinq blessés aujourd'hui
nanterre 21 blessés et récemment
sciences po
bon à sciences po il ya déjà eu un
certain nombre d'incidents
il y en a eu 1 hier soir un café où
étaient attablés cinq militants d'une f1
et 30 et démocratique a été attaqué par
une trentaine de nervis et me demande
une manche de pioche ils ont
heureusement pu se défendre mais café
été complètement dévastées la semaine
dernière des militants de l'unef se sont
faits
course et dans les rues autour de
sciences po par les militants du gld
armés de 30 arrêts la semaine d'avant
étudiants juifs qui avaient eu simple
thor 2
refuser un tract s'est fait ouvrir le
crâne à coups de marteau il était
hospitalisé
une violence qui amène aujourd'hui les
étudiants de gauche a réclamé la
dissolution du cud pour sa part le
collectif des étudiants libéraux proches
de la majorité demandent que le
gouvernement je cite robin de ses
responsabilités pour faire respecter la
liberté du travail à l'université la
politique étrangère a commencé tout
d'abord par les nouvelles en provenance
du tchad le vent a tourné
la capitale djamena est passé ce matin
sous le contrôle des forces
gouvernementales de goukouni oueddei
hissène habré a donc fait retraite et
l'on parle à nouveau ben arbia mine d'un
cessez-le-feu imminent oui c'est vrai
mais l'expérience ou après coach à deux
un cessez-le-feu n'est jamais vraiment
acquis ni surtout lorsqu'il est signée
respectée alors en principe ce qui
devrait se passer dans les prochains
jours peut-être dans les prochaines
heures peut se décomposer en 3.1 dès
l'arrêt des combats
envoi d'une commission de contrôle et
d'une force neutre
composé par le bénin le congo le togo et
la guinée 2 la ville de djamena est
démilitarisé
3 enfin les forces en présence se retire
à 100 km de la capitale bien entendu la
france appuie très fermement les trois
points de cet accord élaboré je vous le
rappelle à lomé le mois dernier la seule
inconnue étant pour le moment la
position des 4000 libier qui se trouve
actuellement au tchad
accepteront ils oui ou non de rentrer
chez eux une fois les combats terminés
je crois que c'est de leur attitude que
va dépendre l'issue de la crise au tchad
dont pour l'instant pas l'intervention
militaire française possible qu'est ce
qui se passerait quant même s'il y avait
cette décision vu de paris haga les
endroits se trouvent les alors je trouve
les forces effectivement il est d'abord
les effectifs retirer de djamena au mois
de mai dernier qui se trouve
actuellement en république
centrafricaine au total 850 hommes 4
jaguar et l'avion avitailleurs qui les
accompagnent à libreville au gabon
ici avec le 6e bataillon d'infanterie de
marine environ 700 hommes qui pourraient
eux aussi intervenir assez rapidement
enfin à djibouti ici à djibouti où sont
stationnés 4000 hommes ainsi qu'une
dizaine de mirage iii reste bien sûr la
france avec la 11ème division
parachutiste dont l'état major est à
toulouse
elle est forte d'environ 12000 homme est
allé spécialement entraîné à intervenir
dans les plus brefs délais voilà donc où
l'on en est ce soir
mais pour le moment on préfère quand
même penser à paris et dans les
capitales africaines que ce
cessez-le-feu
a bien signé et que l'on n'aura pas
besoin de recourir à ces forces
d'intervention france est toujours en
afrique en ouganda après la prestation
de serment du nouveau président milton
obote et l'un de ses prédécesseurs
godfred by nasa a été remis en liberté
pologne lundi prochain sans doute une
réunion internationale à paris des pays
occidentaux afin de déterminer les
conditions d'une aide économique et
financière à varsovie
et ce alors que la pologne s'apprête à
inaugurer dix ans après les événements
tragiques de danse un monument qui est
aussi un symbole philippe chatel près de
mille délégués du nouveau syndicat libre
agricole qui a pris pour nom solidarité
rurale se sont réunis hier à l'institut
polytechnique de varsovie d'abord pour
entendre la messe au cours de laquelle
fut lu un message pastoral avertissant
les polonais des dangers que ferait
courir au pays
toute action est responsable puis pour
débattre ensemble de la réponse à
apporter au refus du tribunal régional
d'enregistrer leur syndicat le principe
d'une grève éventuelle a été retenue
solidarité rurale qui affirme regrouper
600 mille exploitants privés revendique
essentiellement que le gouvernement
mette d'agriculture privé à égalité avec
les fermes d'état pour l'attribution de
machines agricoles de semences et
d'engrais
solidarité rurale participera demain à
gdansk à l'inauguration du monument à la
mémoire des morts de 1970 quand la grève
des ouvriers des chantiers navals avait
été réprimée de manière sanglante
une certaine tension règne en pologne
dans la crainte d'incidents au cours de
cette cérémonie on lévesque à paris une
journée bien remplie docteur honoris
causa de la sorbonne cet après-midi et
puis surtout ce matin un entretien avec
raymond barre et un déjeuner avec le
président giscard d'estaing relais avec
les pros ministre bonjour vous avez
cette jolie formule en parlant la
coopération franco québécoise tout à
l'heure en sortant de matignon vous avez
dit ça a été dans l'huile tout marche
bien
l'atpu cumulus ya encore quelques tout
petits cumulus web parce que ya toujours
des choses à ajuster dans une
coopération surtout quand elle prend des
formes économiques parce qu'il ya des
intérêts en jeu mais je crois que au
dessus des intérêts partisans ou des
intérêts économiques qui se trouve
quelque chose qui est une longueur
d'onde commune et ça c'est permanent
lors les cumulus ne peuvent pas déranger
et aussi à lui plutôt serein et il y
aura besoin d'une impulsion nouvelle à
cette coopération
j'ai toujours besoin d'une impulsion
nouvelle c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle en 77 quand j'avais eu
l'honneur de faire cette visite
officielle ici au début de notre mandat
gouvernement il avait été décidé qu'on
essaierait autant que possible chaque
année d'injecter une volonté politique
avec une présence politique dans cette
coopération parce que sinon ça risque
est toujours d'aller dans la routine
vous répond que les installe un organe
vous avez le sens des formules à la fois
familier et percutant tout à l'heure à
la sorbonne
vous avez dit que ce qui menaçait les
les francophones s'étaient à génocide en
douce qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
c'est le titre d'un ouvrage qui a été
écrit chez nous et qui essaie de
ramasser dans une formule comme celle là
qui est dramatique et titre il faut que
ça ait son drame quand même sinon celle
c'est un profond effet c'est tout
simplement qu'il ya toujours des dangers
d'assimilation y avait danger d'une
espèce de d'homogénéisation culturel en
amérique du nord
oublier qu'en amérique du nord si vous
comptez que la 40 personnes qui vivent
sur ce demi continent et bien il y en a
une sur 40 et qui est francophone et
l'essentiel de cette francophonie et au
québec que leur vie d'amendé cerné de
toutes parts on n'arrive pas bien à
gagner sa vie en parle en français au
canada par exemple au canada je dois
dire que non à l'extérieur le québec ce
qui explique d'ailleurs que nos
minorités hors québec parce qu'on a
quand même des minorités dans l'est du
canada sont toujours sont pas toujours
son de façon permanente et de plus en
plus en danger d'extinction culturel
parce que quand on quand on passe sa vie
dans sa langue très difficile de
persister la deuxième génération en
général disparaît se noie ses 80 %
français c'est 5 millions et quelques
francophones compact et qui ont une
société complète si vous voulez une
société de taille modeste mais qui est
complète qu'il moderne maintenant est de
plus en plus tout le monde peut gagner
sa vie en français prenez les règles
vous avez perdu une grande bataille de
l'année dernière est là un train est ce
que ça veut dire que le québec libre y
en aura jamais on écoute et quelle qu'en
soit la forme je suppose je serai pas
faire du prophétisme mais je crois qu'au
contraire il ya nos amis qui étaient
catastrophés parce que c'était arrivé
comme ça 60% contre 40% pour ce que nous
proposions mais s'il avait analysé enfin
des adversaires qui se frottait les
mains prématurément aussi mais si jamais
analysé le résultat le 40% qui a dit oui
était ce 80% français du québec là où la
solution sera trouvée le jour où elle le
sera et ce 80% français s'est divisée
très exactement 50 50
ce sont les générations montantes
massivement qui ont voté oui parce que
nous proposions et c'est souvent le cas
dans les propositions de changement les
gens qui en entrevue sur les générations
plus proche de leur déclin qui ont tu te
y amener à voter non alors je crois le
sans avoir la prétention parler du
courant de l'histoire ça va se produire
de quelle façon
mais ici s'agit d'assurer par une
encadrement politique
meyer qui répondent mieux aux conditions
de l'évolution du québec et maintenant
vos revenus vous avez pas ressenti ça
comme un échec personnel et d'une
politique
écoutez c'est un échec c'est un échec
mais il faut accepter qu'on perte de nos
factures d eau et d bord de radeaux de
bataille
sûrement sûrement et non seulement sans
le climat est en train je crois de
changer non pas dans un sens
nécessairement de une reprise de ce
qu'ils en aient vécu au moment du
référendum de la société évolue aussi
vite que ça mais une reprise dans ce
sens suivant c'est que il ya des gens à
commencer par notre premier ministre
fédéral qui avoue visité récemment pour
essayer de passer sa marchandise qui
essayent d'abuser de trudeau qui
essaient d'abuser de ce vote
référendaire pour en carcanet le québec
davantage où ils ont fait l'erreur
d'essayer d'en carcanet tout le monde
savait qu'à raddas un pays fédéral
alors il ya maintenant une réaction très
saumâtre contre trudeau et de grains en
train de soi disant rapatriement
constitutionnel enfin je vous vous
entraînez parlant toute la plomberie de
la ferme
son train a déraillé sérieusement et
maintenant l'opération est en danger il
est en grave difficulté
demain c'est vous qui allez gagner et
non mais c'est très dur écoutez ce pour
personnaliser comme ça c'est simplement
comme je trouve doit plus une mauvaise
direction en abusant d'une victoire dont
il a essayé d'attirer le maximum il a
détourné le sens du vote et maintenance
a eu c'est un boomerang saluer revient
dans le visage
ça pourrait pas arriver à quelqu'un plus
indiqué c'est le premier tron va faire
ma pas vrai comme on dit peut-être au
québec ni au canada ni gain en apprenant
que vous veniez où on dirait jamais
baïkal à bord vous dit quand vous sortez
en sécurité ou d'envoyer des mots comme
ça non nous on dirait quelque chose qui
est géré les deux français mais brisure
même gauchement en apprenant que vous
étiez là ce soir brigitte bardot m'a
téléphoné tout à l'heure c'est qu'elle
vous en veut beaucoup parce que vous
appartenez à une nation qui abat les
bébés phoques et que vous avez récemment
augmenté ce quota
et vous êtes passé de 180 milles à 200
mille bébés qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez bas sauf tout le respect que je
dois tout ses autres qualités sont bien
connus et je vais rappellerai simplement
ceci sauf erreur quand il est venu la
première fois elle avait promis a été
avec son mari elle avait promis de
s'installer pour les pauvres pêcheurs
qui ont cherché les bébés phoques une
industrie dédiée
ça c'est une industrie de fourrure
synthétique on l'attend encore en
attendant ils ont besoin des bébés
phoques et ne peux pas l'aider à prêter
en empêchant un peu ce massacre qui
touche maintenant oui je suis content
j'ai toujours remarqué les gars que
c'est assez curieux jeu précis c'est
vrai encore mais la façon dont vous
traitez les oies pour en tirer le foie
gras est quelque chose d'infiniment
barbare qu'est ce qu'on fait aux bébés
phoques sans sa chope et ce avec un coup
de bâton doucement puis de toute façon
c'est trop nombreux et devoirs et tous
les poissons ci avait pas une certain
contrôle comme sap appel à projets noël
il fallait le dire c'est vrai on s'en
est rendu compte les téléspectateurs
s'en sont rendus compte avoir gardé vous
êtes une personnalité attachante avec
des mots vous avez été vous même
journaliste à la radio télévision
canadienne à radio-canada show tour
l'animateur alimente un reporter vous
seriez capable de continuer un petit peu
le journal à ma place en lisant juste à
paragraphe 2 jusqu'à la suite du journal
vous mangez averti que vous auriez pu me
faire lire avant l'ajout du délire
s'agit de l'italie il voit dans l'utah
les détails et ça nous frappe tous chez
nous parce qu'on a une très grosse
colonie italienne qui a été terriblement
peur tu est sidéré même par ce qui vient
de se passer car on a parlé des brigades
rouges et du trop long entre un appel
pathétique
hier soir à la télévision de l'épousé du
magistrat romain enlevé par les brigades
rouges c'est pas tout à fait le même
sujet pour l'instant les enquêteurs ne
disposent que de maigres indices
et puis à naples trois semaines après le
tremblement de terre
un palais du 14e siècle s'est effondré
hier soir en se glissant huit personnes
âgées et une religieuse le bâtiment
avait été partiellement évacuée après le
séisme les services techniques de la
municipalité devait faire une inspection
de sécurité
aujourd'hui même
voilà mais c'est promis je vous remercie
beaucoup je crois que vous pouvez pas
beaucoup deux premiers dans le monde qui
acceptent de de se livrer à ce je vous
remercie beaucoup on peut pas diminuer
l'impact des nouvelles non non mais je
crois que vous l'avez bien du chemin
salut merci en justice le procès des
autonomistes bretons devant la cour de
sûreté de l'état les dernières
plaidoiries ont été prononcées ce matin
le pays vit une situation de
colonisation a dit l'un des défenseurs à
l'instant vient de tomber
l'arrêt de la cour de sûreté de l'état
elle a infligé des peines allant de deux
ans de prison avec sursis
à 13 ans de réclusion criminelle à 9
autonomiste breton 1/10 inculpés et ans
a quitté la cour d'assises de paris elle
a condamné à 15 ans de réclusion
criminelle des trois principaux auteurs
de l'enlèvement du banquier mallet enfin
à la suite d'un jugement du tribunal
adminstratif françois boissarie délégué
du syndicat national des journalistes a
été réintégré au figaro plus de trois
ans et demi après son licenciement
la guerre du pain suite nouveau record à
battre 95 centimes pour 200 g de pain
demain amar le bac et opu 95 centimes à
saint-avold aujourd'hui on était à 98
centimes les consommateurs de l'ufc
disent bravo à condition que la qualité
ne soit pas touché new york
en deuil hier soir cinq cent mille
personnes ont rendu hommage à la mémoire
de john lennon dans central park à
quelques mètres de l'immeuble où
habitait l'ancien b peu abattu devant
son entrée pendant ce temps à liverpool
sa ville natale quelques vingt mille
personnes ont entonné en choeur l'hymne
de ceux qui célèbrent samson
d'une fille qui tient à donner une
chance à la paix
la paix une raison d'espérer nous allons
en parler dans question de temps tout à
l'heure et dans une page spéciale de ce
journal mais auparavant il faut que je
vous parle sport pour vous dire que
c'est l'autrichien weirather qui l'a
emporté dans la descente à val gardena
aujourd'hui que je vous parle météo pour
vous dire que comme vous voyez
aujourd'hui les températures étaient
particulièrement douces et que demain
des averses de pluie neige seront
observées le matin sur le nord est et
les alpes elles s'atténueront en cours
de journée sur le reste de la france le
temps sera plus frais surtout de matam
et ensuite les éclaircies sont assez
belle les vents de nord ouest resteront
assez fort que je vous dise enfin qu'un
nouveau journal vient de paraître et
renouvelle et puis que je vous fixe les
prochains rendez vous demain quand elle
ne me dit aura pour invités professeur
toubiana le spécialiste du cancer
exceptionnellement vous pourrez lui
poser des questions en appelant demain
dès midi svp 22-22 et ce numéro
seulement à 23h10 paul amar et à 20h35
donc question dans ce soir les raisons
d'espérer
d'abord un sondage réalisé par la sofres
pour antenne 2 face à l'avenir 38%
d'optimiste 58% de pessimistes quant aux
raisons d'espérer en elle même il ya
tout d'abord les progrès de la recherche
médicale
nous en parlerons avec maurice tubiana
plus les nouvelles découvertes
techniques et scientifiques le
développement économique et social
enfin la sagesse humaine et la
renaissance des valeurs morales et et
terrasses et a voulu savoir quelles
étaient les raisons d'espérer quand on a
70 ans et plus bref quand on rentre de
ce qu'on appelle le troisième âge
regardez ce reportage très émouvant de
patricia cost et de jacques aubertin il
nous apprend plein de choses
en cinq minutes
le blog salon vin je me présente
monsieur chauveau mouiller chauveau
combien étiez anciens clichés oui et
aurait eu revin we begin délit dans la
vie faut pas s'en faire
moi j'ai l'espoir d'être en bonne santé
depuis longtemps possible et vous
mettiez ayant atteint 83 eur tout doit
arriver à s'entendre aussi bien que
maintenant chez tout un
hippolyte poulbot maurice chevaux
anciens caissier sur les champs de
courses petit retraité parisien belote
billard apéritif et parfois un voyage
organisé camarades depuis 40 ans l'un
croit en quelque chose
l'autre aime la danse mais pour tous les
deux l'espoir c'est avant tout la vie
leur vie moi je ne m'ennuie jamais
j'adore la société j'ai des copains et
les copines mais quand jésus je suis
seulement je ne m'ennuie jamais non plus
c'est pareil il manque de rien ça me va
bien avec celui qu'elle deux ou trois
choses que venue quelques chats veaux
laitiers terrain celui qui loge moins
vingt plus grandes villes du terrail
primature une maison de plus en plus
grande
je me contentais je m'adapte à ce que
j'ai j'ai de la veine que ça va à peu
près comme enfin c'est ça le faux
médecin traitant
les gens qui l'ont pas l'idéal je me
demande comment il dit comprenez vous
alors ce soir c'est comment dirais-je
rabaisser rôle de la bête vous comprenez
qu'on peut vous souhaiter la candidate
monsieur chevaux il a un idéal
probablement un idéal
il l'habille comprenez vous elle a ri
tort d'en profiter
mieux qu'il peut moi personnellement
j'ai toujours me dit alors le militant
anti ch
il est basé sur l'espoir si on n'avait
pas le square pourquoi habilité c'est
pourquoi à brescia je vous dirais comme
ce l'était pour la télévision
je vais vous dire quelque chose tu ne
peux pas vous dire pourquoi je me dis
que ce n'est pas parce que j'étais il ya
trois ans que je renie les idées que
j'ai eu jusqu'à présent
comprenez vous ça vous dit en cas le
tient encore à coeur mais tu es bon goût
dont la pleine bourre et vous faites la
cuire ce matin grand boulevard à la caf
gir 6 vouloir sauter à la ville et les
hisser les sondes soucieuse et réfléchir
mais pourquoi elle fléchit
moi j'ai un petit musée lui est toujours
seul espoir quant aux concessionnaires
en amérique mais arrivés des états et
des trucs formidables
nous sommes montés au 96e étals
d'animapp qu'était le plus grand
d'amérique à chicago 96e et al c'est un
danseur est vrai laisse alors vous savez
c'est une espèce de discothèque à
l'américaine c'est très grave
pas sûr
c'est un jour le soir surtout que cet
illuminé ou et milliards de lumière et
bien donc nous a lancé tout ça y est les
américains qui sont précipités sur lui
font danser avec lui en donnez vous mais
alors il y en a une elle était tellement
chanté avant moi ce soir sur le fait
d'embrasser fromage également jeté à
l'eau
que voulez vous
pourquoi
des quoi l'espoir l'espoir c'est de
continuer avec une bonne santé mais dans
ma lecture
coiffé le salut doit pouvoir
participer encore un petit pont
collectivités à des activités que vous
permettre de vivre
ils mentent en afrique mais c'est très
dur la solitude
le club de danse donc c'est l'espoir de
pour mousser l'espoir de rencontrer des
gens très agréables en parts dans un
milieu qui est le nôtre et with bat
maintenant atteindre bon mais je dis
j'ai mis plusieurs années avant de
prendre cette décision pour faire pas
parce que je m'étais enfermé et rendu le
prix c'est ce qu'ils n'étaient quant au
bonheur quoi i la retraite idéale pour
vous c'est quoi leur offre est idéale ça
c'est de pouvoir continuer avec une
compagne qui malheureusement n'est
probable
c'est le préfet leur vie avec un crayon
un problème nous
j'ai mes favorites on m'a dit il y avait
il ya un couple ils sont connus là
même jeunesse aux vingt ans comment la
barre tellement passionnant et vue
vous avez travaillé de survie et les lui
la retraite est ce que c'est la seule
une virus au commencement du nom
mais la liberté
les forêts
j'adore la gambie la gambie
et noël pour vous une fête de l'espoir
la chaîne fait pour les enfants sont où
et comment situez chagrin
et dangereux
faire vivre deux
donc tout à l'heure tout de suite après
une page de publicité les raisons
d'espérer une émission de jean pierre
elkabbach et de louis blériot en direct
du musée de l'homme avec andrée dans un
du club de rome avec l'entrée en gagnent
et autres anthropologues avec des
reportages notamment serez liane qui
vous le savez et revient d'ouganda avec
norbert segard ce ministre atteint du
cancer et qu'il l'a dit un village qui
se mobilise contre le fromage en
aquitaine et découvertes dans la
biologie et l'énergie et traitera donc
question dans très spécial une soirée
sur les raisons d'espérer
bonsoir à tous à demain